it's it's pretty incredible how
political all of american life
has become i have a bevy of stories
about this today so
coca-cola has now decided that they are
going to
force their employees to take
anti-racism training
with the excremental robin d'angelo
robin d'angelo is
the worst public intellectual in america
she's awful she's a cult leader
if you read her book her garbage book
white fragility
the entire argument that she makes is
that black people cannot take care of
their own future that white liberals
like robin deangelo have to take care of
black people's future that black people
by dint of being black
are systematically discriminated against
and that white people who fail to
recognize this suffer from white
fragility the only solution to which is
to listen to robin d'angelo on what she
tells you
the only way that you can clear yourself
of the racist
of the racist drippings that that have
adhered to you
is by taking a 20 000 diversity course
from robin to angelo
so coca-cola duly did this because this
is what corporations do corporations are
afraid of liability
they're afraid that someone will sue
them for discrimination and so
they hire people like rob and deangelo
to give them the cover
to continue to do business they feel
like okay fine so for 20 grand
now i can say when i'm when i'm sued by
some upset
employee that we gave everybody the
anti-racism training
okay so robin d'angelo was doing this
training and we have some screen caps
from this particular training here are
some of the screen screen caps
confronting racism understanding what it
means to be white
challenging what it means to be racist
solid stuff here from
robin to angelo okay to be less white
okay so here's how right we don't want
you to be white we want to be less white
which um okay this isn't racist at all
by the way
to be less white is to be less
oppressive be less arrogant be less
certain
be less defensive be less ignorant
be more humble listen believe break with
apathy break with white solidarity now
we need to take a moment here to explain
what exactly robin deangelo is saying
again this is coca-cola employees being
subjected to this overt racism
because if you're white this means that
you're oppressive arrogant certain
defensive ignorant humble
you must not humble you need to be you
need to listen and believe
you're apathetic and you have white
solidarity if you're white so you need
to be less white
i don't know how like really how are you
less white
she doesn't mean that you color your
skin obviously that's racist instead
what you mean
is that you have to be a a person who
listens to robin d'angelo
you are by being a white person
oppressive
unless you recognize that you're
oppressive in which case you're not
you're less white in some way
you're arrogant if you're white despite
you might think of yourself as not
arrogant wrong
wrong because now you're engaging in
defensiveness
right this is the stupid little game she
plays it's perverse game
right she says you're oppressive and
you're arrogant and you're certain about
all your stuff you're like well no i
don't feel like i've oppressed anybody
and as far as arrogance i mean frankly
i kind of know what i'm good at and what
i'm not good at and i'm not good at a
lot of things and i'm not super certain
actually in fact i have a lot less
certainty than robin d'angelo
so i kind of deny this stuff and she
goes you're being defensive
right if you fight back against her now
you're defensive which means you're
being white again
stop that you have to be less ignorant
right because you're ignorant because
you're white you say well no i'm not i'm
not ignorant actually i know a lot of
things nope
there you are being defensive again you
need to be more humble
which um i love that just to fill out
this slide she had be less arrogant and
also be more humble
which is the same thing you have to
listen and believe
listen and believe okay if i listen and
believe she means
that if someone tells you that they feel
that they have been subjected to some
sort of predation by another person
you can't evaluate the evidence you
can't say okay well i understand you
feel that way
the feeling may be authentic but what is
the evidence to back whether the feeling
is justified
authentic and justified are two very
different things a lot of people feel
things authentically that are not
justified by the underlying fact pattern
this happens all the time
my kids feel authentically angry at me
on a variety of bases that does not mean
that their feelings are justified
my son yesterday was time for him to go
to bed and my son
decided that he did not want to go to
bed right
and he was very angry at me because i
said we have to stop playing legos you
need to go to bed his feelings were
authentic they were not justified it was
time for him to go to bed
by the way he was so upset at this that
he then went and peed on the floor
because this is what children do funny
now wasn't it
it wasn't at the time his feelings were
authentic peeing on the floor was not
justified in any case
listen and believe is what robin
deangelo says you must believe
you have to break with apathy because
what she means by break with apathy
is you just have to mirror everything
she says or you're apathetic and finally
you have to break with white solidarity
because you understand
if you refuse to go along with what
she's saying this means that essentially
you're a white solidarity supremacist
so let's say that you don't really want
to listen to this racist anti-racist
training nonsense instead you'd rather
listen to music or you know enjoy your
life
that's when you would grab these your
rakons and you would pop them directly
in your ears they are fantastic raycon
is disrupting the electronics industry
by designing
premium wireless audio for half the
price without compromise they're doing
things differently than other brands out
there from the way they design their
products to the way they price them
raycon prioritizes their customer
experience start to finish raycon offers
their wireless earbuds in a range
of fun colors and patterns with a
variety of fit options no dangling wires
no stems the company was co-founded by
ray j celebrities like snoop dogg mike
tyson are obsessed with raycons plus i
love them
raycon has a day free return policy
raycon earbuds will give you six hours
of playtime seamless bluetooth pairing
more bass and more compact design for a
comfortable noise isolating fit so
recon wireless zippers are the best way
to bring your favorite content with you
wherever
you go i love my raycons because view
they fit perfectly in these years so
click the link in the description box or
go to buyrecon.com
shapiro yt to get 15 off your raycon
purchase again that is by raycon.com
shapiro yt to get 15 off your recon
purchase
okay then here's more from robin
d'angelo training the uh the unlucky
suckers over at coca-cola in the us and
other western nature
nations white people are socialized to
feel that they are inherently superior
because they are white
research shows that by age three to four
children understand that it is better to
be white
oh is that what the research shows is it
now
huh interesting also um i'm just go
white people are socialized to feel they
are inherently superior because they're
right actually no the civil rights
movement
socializes to believe that people should
be treated as individuals
it is your educational training that
makes white people feel that they are
superior
because it is only white people who can
solve the problems for black people it's
something shelby steele pointed out
in his own book white guilt which is one
of the beautiful things about being
somebody like robin d'angelo is the only
person who can solve the problem
is white people you still get to be
superior for if you're rob and d'angelo
you still get paid 20 grand to fix
america's racial problems because you're
owning it
you see and finally try to be less white
honestly this should be like the 1984
apple commercial
it's just robin deangelo talking to you
like big brother until somebody comes in
with the with the race
with the with the logic hammer and
flings it at the screen try to be less
white
okay so coca-cola a massive company
hired
robin deangelo to teach this crap to the
people who work at coca-cola
yes your corporate overlords they are
willing to buy into this stuff now
question why are they willing to buy
into this stuff the reason they are
willing to buy into this stuff is for
really three reasons one the people who
are buying into this stuff
do so because they're afraid of boycott
and they're afraid really of publicity
they understand that if you are
perceived as a liberal corporation fewer
people are going to come after you
right that is that is a rationale for
doing this
there's a study i've cited it before
from harvard business review it showed
that if you put together
a a focus group of of people from all
different political sides of the aisle
and you ask them about a corporation and
you ask them about the corporation being
formed in three different ways one as a
politically neutral corporation
two as a political politically liberal
corporation and three as a conservative
corporation
the crowd's reaction be wildly different
if you just said same corporation it's
neutral people are like okay sounds good
if you said it was liberal people were
like okay sounds good if you said it was
conservative
the positivity ratings dropped by 33
percentage points all among people who
were lefty
coca-cola understands this if they are
perceived to be the lefty corporation
they understand that people on the right
will still buy coke and people on the
left will be more apt to buy coke unless
they opt to go after them
so that is reason number one reason
number two it shields them from
liability
and reason number three because most of
the people who now run these corporate
boards
are people who are liberal they have no
systemic intellectual defense against
the hard left
people who are liberal and innately
believe
in the guilt of the united states but
they also believe in certain individual
rights
the problem is if you believe in the
innate guilt of the united states and
the innate evil of the united states
it's very hard to also believe
in the goodness and rightness of the
individual rights upon which the united
states is predicated you can't both
believe that america's ideas
start in 1619 and that america's ideas
start in 1776. these are mutually
exclusive beliefs
so you got to pick a lot of liberals are
picking 16 19
because it makes them feel better about
themselves okay so that's what's
happening over at coca-cola and this
sort of stuff has
infused so many different corporations
you see it obviously over at disney
and not only did disney plus lucasfilm
decide to fire gina carano for no good
reason simply because she didn't go
along
with the woke left but now they've
decided to hit the muppets
with an offensive content label now this
was the most predictable thing in all
the land they announced that you'd be
able to watch
the muppets on disney plus i immediately
tweeted out that within three weeks the
swedish chef would be cancelled
it was perfectly obvious i was wrong it
didn't take three weeks it took
three days disney has now slapped the
muppet show with an offensive content
disclaimer
the muppet show the warning also appears
in front of bambi
well not not bambi right bambi's okay
cause it's just about deer right
aristocats
dumbo peter pan and of course swiss
family robinson
all great movies all apparently
unmentionable
hey and then you've got cartoon network
now pushing anti-racism okay
so so you've got robin d'angelo not just
teaching coca-cola but mainstreamed into
cartoon network now it's one thing to
get mad at the muppets from 1987 for
telling a joke
that you now consider culturally
insensitive 30 years later it's another
thing to get mad at cartoon network
when cartoon network is literally just
putting out psas
mirroring for children mirroring robin
deangelo's talking points on racism and
indoctrinating kids into overtly racist
garbage
here is the cartoon network pushing what
is obviously racism
well i'm not an alien but it definitely
matters to me that i'm black
yeah it makes a difference that i'm
white i know the two of us get treated
very differently
my experience with anti-black racism is
really specific
other people of color experience other
forms of racism too
but you won't see any of that if you
don't see color can we get a rewrite
where we appreciate each other without
erasing what makes each of us different
okay but it's gonna add a couple hours
to the shoot i can't make yours open
uh you were rolling just now weren't you
can't we just slap some graphics on this
and call it a day
hmm see color be anti-racist
shut up racist children see color
be anti-racist so yes we are all
supposed to see each other
as people of different colors whose
experiences are completely
non-understandable i cannot
understand your experience in any way
and because i can't understand your
experience this is the robin d'angelo
stuff i have to listen and believe
i can never try to assess whether your
opinion on a matter
is non-factually or evidentiarily based
instead i have to listen and believe
because you see
i see color so i'm an anti-racist which
means i have to listen and believe
whatever you say
and presumably accept all of your policy
recommendations as well in order to
destroy the systems of power
this is being taught to children at
cartoon network
to children yeah you wonder why people
feel like they're under assault because
they're under
they're under assault i hope you enjoyed
that clip from the ben shapiro show if
you did
go ahead and hit the subscribe button so
you stay up to date on all of our future
content